From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, Joe Lurwell.
This is Tuesday, the 24th of May 2011. My name is Joe Manye of the Southern Old History Program.
The University of North Carolina in Chapel Hill. I'm the Oklahoma City Oklahoma with filmmaker John Bishop.
And we are here at the Looper Household as part of the Library of Congress and Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture Civil Rights Law History Project entitled The Civil Rights History Project.
And we are sitting down this afternoon with Mr. Cal Aluper. Good to be with you Mr. Looper. Thank you for welcoming us to Oklahoma.
It's good for you all to come through the storm, struggle through the storm. I think that was a poem or a song somewhere through the storm we made it.
From that support we shall overcome somewhere.
There's some heavy weather out the window here in Oklahoma. We're keeping our eye on that.
We're all keeping our eye on it. Mr. Looper, I want to ask a range of questions. No problem.
Here about those years in the struggle in Oklahoma City, about your mother, about your family. Maybe I'll ask you just to talk a little bit about the Youth Council and what you recall from its early days.
Okay, you made me think of warning you. We're not going to play the dozens. I don't do the dozens.
I think you can remember back in the days when the people used to stand on the corner and talk about your mother.
What they do, they do that with me. But then they go get a newspaper and come back.
Those days were great. Marlon went over and told me how we went to New York City with the movie Brother President.
And fortunately, in a way I still have the film from that, but I'll run it into a problem and I'll make a duplicate of it.
You've got a film from your trip to New York City?
No, on the presentation of the play Brother President. It's down at one of our local photo shops here at Piffkins.
Well, they're trying to duplicate it and put it on the CD DVD or something.
From 50's up?
No, this would be 58.
Tell me about some of the other members of the Society of your sister. Some of the other members of the Youth Council.
You had a chance to meet my cousin, Betty Germany, that was here.
Very briefly, yeah.
And sort of was a family affair there at first because where one went, all of us went.
There was another cousin, Richard Brown, who was one of the original cityers.
And so we were all there because my mom said so. And my grandmother said, do a Clara said and didn't have to tell me that we should have told Betty there because Betty was sitting there.
We were going and I were happy to be there. Well, we couldn't miss the meeting because the meeting was in the house.
And it's I mentioned earlier, this dear couch, poured with Williams, it's recoded.
I think that was about in 1980 something you recoded.
Because it was a victim of the city in movement.
It's been slept on by many and set on by hundreds.
And I'm bleeding that one of those Molotov cocktails that came through the front door.
It kind of scorched one of them.
It had a red cover on it.
Red upholster is no longer.
Richard is my one of them.
So, there's a lot of little memories.
As you were talking with my older brother, there's a lot of the memories coming back to my hand. That bus ride.
I think we were talking about that on the phone. I thought you had felt when I got to do your accident and had a chance to go to the lunch and that.
And to give me a sandwich or what I wanted and put my money in there and watch it go around and around and choose my own sandwich with nobody.
I help you out. No, you can't eat here. Get out of here.
And riding the elevator in a Hudson hotel. Up and down, up and down.
Going, walking through the lobby without having to worry about being told to get out of there.
Because down in Toronto, Club of City, the skirving and the hookings, there was a no-no unless you work there.
And of course being a looper, they wouldn't, they wouldn't, they weren't good until they had me to work in there.
That was a hard thing to find. That's one of the things that happened during the city and it didn't have to.
I was rolling and I both had a hard time with it and that was getting employment.
You know, I had kids with good jobs during the summer shoot.
It's all right collecting cans. I'll put it just a little.
Remember that first night at Cats?
They all kind of run together. I can remember many of the time walking.
Waiting on the car to get parked and then walking across the main street and going there through the doorway.
There, at Main and Broadway, it was the main doorway and then it's the one we were using.
I picked it up and picked it up. It would be on the main street side.
Because Main and Main and Ryan was east and west.
Broadway was north and south and there.
I mean, make it break it on home to you.
Today, where the Ford Theatre is, is the formerly the home of the Cats Drug Store.
Every time I see a game, be it on TV or in person or past theatre, I think about the many of them morning, many evening.
In the hour, we spent on that location thunder-ized before they even had that team there.
So, it has a double special meeting to them.
Merlin mentioned about never trying to be able to try on a hat.
Not that I wanted to that much anyway.
And the shoes, the way big one, when you start to do it.
I think she left off the part about how big my mother was.
The buss, buses would change there in front of Johnny Browns.
My grandmother stayed out in Carverdale, addition, which was a mostly black addition of North East Tenth and Martin Luther King now.
But back then, the buss were in there and it would take, she'd ride the bus down there and then change over to catch it, transfer over to them.
Whichever one was, it was a technical seal and ride that.
That's early in the morning and then in the evening.
Excuse me, I'm just grabbing the ride grandmother took your way away.
And of course, she reversed us coming back home.
I can say, home, because 1236 Windermere was her address.
And all of those people, bad and rich at a night.
And when it was home, us too.
Because she was a willing babysitter.
Your mother had a busy schedule?
Yes, she did.
Especially keeping up with us and our friends.
And I said, keep it up with us.
I mean, not outside of the city because she knew where we were.
I had mentioned to you two about the self-discipline that we had within the city and the youth council.
And there was an organization called the Commanders.
And job was to not only keep outsiders from messing with the people inside,
keep us from messing up on the inside or doing things that we knew we shouldn't be doing.
And my mom also emphasized on bringing a school book with you, what are your books with you?
Why you be sitting there?
And it would be sitting even at cats and then even at Bishop's Restaurant.
And we could get in there because at Bishop's Restaurant, they were really slick.
They fixed the door away.
They had the doors locked.
You couldn't open the door.
So we stand part of us would be outside.
Those that got there late would still be outside.
But those of us that had been there on time and been able to get in,
and we used all the account means to get in there.
But once we got in there, we didn't just sit there looking at the glass of water and the silverware.
But I got to use that time to do some kind of study.
Not that we remembered much, not that I remembered much.
I don't know how others are still.
But I believe during that time I was taking my first year in Spanish.
And this bad always was taking that book with me.
Because I kept my eye out on looking around for my sister and my mother.
And of course my sister's friends were like my little sisters.
And even though everybody was doing it, I still felt the additional responsibility and a way for what was mine.
And my own, that's when we started calling a baby.
And to this day she still was outside the name baby.
Because she was everybody's baby.
Tell me if you would about what someone who was watching a lot of those sit-ins as an observer,
what they would have seen in your mother the way she described some of the difficult situations she confronted and how she reacted.
I'm trying to think of something. I mean there's so many.
I think the biggest one is when she would initially meet the restaurant owners.
And now instead of standing back and shying down and looking, you know, oftentimes we had the habit of not looking the person in the eye
and talking to them, but kind of like doing the Negro shuffle.
And the such thing existed with my own.
Okay, well she was talking with the governor of the mayor of police chief.
She looked straight in the face and go from there.
And she would practice in a way, I don't know, I'm probably getting here because she would mind what I always,
she knew about what she was going to say in a way depending on where she was going.
Reason I know that. I worked with her on the Clara Luparello show for 30-something years,
and I was never saying the word in again.
And we'd go out to the radio station, which was on Southeast 44th and Bryant.
And that's where the way is.
And she'd kind of run over whatever we might want to talk about doing that hour radio.
And as I was thinking about this interview, I was thinking of saying,
sort of like Amos and Andy Momu would throw it out there and I had to bat it back.
I'd come up with a joke and she'd react to it.
I could say things that she couldn't just in sound right.
People say we still have hundreds of tapes of radio shows.
It's always been a shared experience with my own.
It's been a challenge just trying to keep up with.
She would lose me off. She would lose me with that congressional record.
Because I learned to read too about history.
I was a history major, but I just got distracted by thinking too much.
I'm in school at OU, but I'm not thinking about what's happening at home
when my mom was sister.
So to make an excuse, what excuse? That's one excuse.
My grade is suffered.
But as I got older, I just said, well, I don't need me worrying about this.
I have something else to do.
My dad was electrician.
I went to a trade school at a kind of a knowledge in there so that I could get a license.
And there, the electrical work for years, a couple of years before my dad died.
We worked together. That was fun.
So I've been watching it extremely, extremely, watching it.
And I've had a chance to work with both my brothers in different, difficult and different situations.
Did you visit young man in say the mid to late 60s?
Did you perspective about race relations, about social change?
Did they pretty much maintain a consistent trajectory in power?
Did you ever have occasion to reconsider the old question on violence, the old question?
Certainly.
Especially when I got proficient with weaponry.
After my little time in the service, I was tempting to associate with the path that's what there is.
I looked at it and had enough of depth.
It was what's next.
Except that we black power, we're going to take care of that.
What you're going to do with your fist?
And the man over there has a gun.
You got a fist.
Whereas with non-violence, you can deal with a person's heart.
You deal with their heart and they might have a balance.
You have that one blow and that's it.
And then blood.
Somebody got to know how to heal you to fix your up.
So somewhere down the line, you got to be knowledgeable on medicine.
And we're at a hitter person.
If you're really going to try to fight because everybody else back there was learning it.
The judo and stuff.
So you can run around and be non-violence.
There's always somebody tougher than you.
Now, maybe somebody's smarter, but I don't mind that as much as getting into a challenging situation.
And getting beaten up, beating up, I'm much rather...
You get a higher grade than I do to get my tail kicked to prove a point.
Did you ever...
Did you ever think that the price paid by the family in these different ways,
the time away from your mother, all of her involvement, the risk, the ability to buy one?
Did it seem too much for your family to pay sometimes?
Not doing that.
I think last 20 years, it's crossed my mind several times.
And so why did mom do this?
Why did we do that ever, Sarah?
Now, I'm Sarah the Morning Still.
I'm up the radio show.
We started nine, so I still find myself getting up and being ready to go somewhere by now.
We started to sit in and I'm Sarah the Mornings.
We'd be at the church started by nine o'clock, say, this is the time we started.
This is the time the business is with the open.
And we'd have to be there.
We'd be there.
We'd have to go by, I'm thinking, Cal, right back to church, where we were off to,
we would meet before we went downtown.
And what it was was an opportunity to review the...
Where were we going?
And...
Just once I've been getting a broad start.
I think I heard Merlin, that's what I was thinking.
It was once, for once, I'm sorry about that.
Okay, we're back on.
Okay, we had Cal, we'd be able to search.
I'm thinking at that time as I remember it was Reverend Kerry.
Yeah, me, I remember Reverend Morris Kerry, who was a pastor.
And Cal, we was relatively close to downtown.
We could walk from Cal, to the cats or to bishops or to Johnny Browns.
And that's where you see a lot of the pictures of the kids on the side while it would be us going down there.
Who's going to step into memory as among that group most important to your mother as her allies and supporters and friends?
People, do you think really matter to her as key allies in that effort?
I think everyone did.
I know that Reverend...
Sorry.
Reverend Bratzinger was a minister at Fifth Street back to Sturge.
Anytime he would call him on, we would stop whatever she was doing.
What she would do that for anybody and talk with them.
Then there was...
Reverend Alexander, who was the AME minister.
And Kellham, I have you in the AME church.
13th in Cal, then there was Dr. Taza and Akkins, who was a brilliant man.
He and Mom, without some intense debates, seriously, sitting on the scouts here, you know, about what...
You know, whatever, particularly on what kind of strategy should we use.
We use the heck of a strategist.
Because it always seems to work.
It's usually from the Bahamas.
I think he moved Oklahoma City.
He ended up...
I'm not ended up, but he was married to our current young lady who went on to become our state representative, Hannah Akkins, was his wife.
And their son Ed and I were real tight.
But Dr. Taza Akkins helped Mom with many of the speech.
And with many way of helping to get kids attention to help to get that non-violent thing down right.
Even though I decided to look on the city more than moving, everybody was doing anything.
There in North Carolina too.
But you know, every group you have to have to speak to them a little differently.
And Dr. Akkins was braiding with that.
And they were close all the way up until even while he was sick, they were still close.
And then his death was affected this whole community.
We all missed him.
He brought many of baby into this world.
Help those of us with that.
The other illnesses.
As well as the arthritis.
I think you ran arthritis off the east side.
That's the one.
That was another little later on.
There was a turning porter, emailing porter.
And we had met him and they coming back from New York, coming back from presenting the play.
I remember we came through Nashville.
And as an inspiration, we were stopping through the college there.
But somehow the porter saw the Oklahoma banner that we had on the bus.
And he was from Oklahoma.
So he made a dash to the bus.
Got on the bus and got to tell everybody about how he was at Vanderbilt Law School.
And when he got out, he was going to come to Oklahoma City.
And he was going to open up a law firm here.
And sure enough, he did.
And it up in the state center.
And the sons of working.
They had to continue the law firm as a today.
It's on Northwest 23rd and Hudson.
Melvin Jr. and Joel.
Thank you, Mom.
I'm playing a little bit of credit in your book for...
You brought him to come back to Oklahoma?
Right.
Did you think she would be interested?
I don't know.
I know she did because he was out in the house.
We were out in the go-by there.
He was brilliant.
He was a law firm.
Well, I think what he was, he knew his way through the law book.
If he didn't know it, he knew where to go get it.
And that seemed to be the key to the law.
The portal was good and he was eloquent.
And then too many lawyers in the city like to come up against him.
Particularly after he got to be a state senator, he was down the mat on the floor.
We all...
Everyone loved him and presented the issue.
Or defended the issue.
But those are two good ones.
And there was another Sam Cornieus who was...
You might still...
You know, he's dead.
They still might try to fire him.
But he was a director of the East Side, the YMCA.
It's where it...
And that's also where we used to have a Monday night meetings before we had the Freedom Center going.
If they weren't at the house, we'd be at the YMCA.
Sam Cornie used to make that possible.
And he was very well-spirited, that's a job.
And he had a beautiful wife who was thinking three kids.
Now I don't think his wife was beautiful.
She was beautiful.
Three kids, I'm trying to count the kids.
It's all the time.
I'm asking the gym.
What on the maintainer?
Did you know...
They were all support?
Yes, I did.
Can you tell me about that?
They told me.
They told me, it's up your fish.
Yes, I did.
They would come by and she would come by.
I know Bruce is son now real well.
And her daughter Charlene was a good friend of mine.
Classmate of mine, we graduated from Douglas High School
together at Charlene.
And where they stayed out in Gordon Oaks,
had a good friend and stayed near them on Oprah's Drive.
And we often would be out there in the street
as she would pass by.
I could call her a second mom because I couldn't mess up
out that way either.
She was necessarily disciplined.
But my bail would help her tell my mother about it.
And everybody knew about it.
The Board of Education.
Can you explain for the tape what that joke
Board of Education means?
The Board of Education was mom's way of discipline.
That was before child abuse.
Because of child abuse back then, who
knows, might not have been in the city.
But the Board of Education got broken in real good
during the city and moving.
That was switched up?
No, it was no switch.
It was a board.
It was one of the teachers there, Dungee School,
and made a board out of it.
I don't know what kind of word it was.
I know who made it to.
Alexander Jones, who, mom used to,
they used to commute to Dungee School together.
He taught mechanical arts.
We taught woodworking, carpentry, mom would teach history.
He also stayed in the 1500 block of North East Park.
And his car was running.
Where mom was moving the 1800 block on park.
And the car wasn't running.
So he'd come by down the hill, pick mom up,
and then he'd ride out to Dungee together.
Did you ever know he would have been older than your mother
on by a stretch?
But did you ever know Professor McClure?
McClure.
No.
He was in that group that helped
de-sacrificate the university.
But he was a little older.
Trying to think of one of his relatives
was quite, was there quite a bit.
I can see him.
I believe he was on the board of the white, why, why you say him.
John, can you always remember?
OK.
It's from, you can.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American history
and culture.